opinion on cryo surgery for debulking so we've had patients with breast cancer that did cryo surgery
a cryo surgery bestitis and I gladly share the doctor who did that except he retired
so they're not in business anymore because he was he was just kind of at a cutting edge in his
later years and he's retired and not practicing anymore but yeah I think you know there's this
that person was very happy with their surgery so but quite honestly there's you know if you go
to a skilled surgeon no matter how they do the surgery I think that that you could be happy with
the surgery so partly you know just so much depends on the skill of the surgeon um so that's
where I always say if you're gonna do a lumpectomy or mastectomy or any surgery you have to be really
comfortable with the person that's doing it you feel like they're not just an ego maniac but they
really are skilled surgeon who really cares about their patients and if you feel good about that
then that's important if you don't feel good about that to just get second opinions because it's
it's important to for you to feel confident in it